There are examples of most resources on the HL7 FHIR site in XML,
JSON and Turtle formats.
Any student taking this course is probably familiar with XML and JSON.
Turtle, Terse RDF Triple Language,
is a format used by the World Wide Web Consortium,
W3C, in its Resource Description Framework,
RDF data model for the proposed semantic web.
RDF extends the linking structure of the web using Uniform Resource Identifiers, URIs,
to describe relationships between things,
as well as the two ends of the link in a triple,
comprising a subject, predicate and object,
each of which can be a URI.
This informal graph from the W3C RDF primer shows
how this construct could power a semantic web
that understands entities and their relationships.
Here as is often the case,
the Mona Lisa is at the center of attention.
Here we see that Bob is a person who likes
this painting that was created by Leonardo da Vinci.
As in our earlier discussion of semantic interoperability,
it is worth considering whether there is a need for
a semantic formalism in an era when machines are increasingly figuring these things out.
I have posted links to the HL7 FHIR site's discussion of
RDF and to the W3C Semantic Web Health Care and Life Sciences Interest Group.